on va passer au raid de l'Arbre Vert que
j'ai énoncé en sommaire de l'émission
avec nous sur ce plateau pour en parler
deux participantes Isabelle reynaldi et
Nathalie Gauthier toutes les deux donc
50 innoise et participantes au raid de
l'Arbre Vert bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
alors première question
juste deux mots dans quel état d'esprit
avons avant d'être vous avant de partir
très excité si c'était demain je pars
demain très très envie d'y aller et
voilà très excité la quête de vous deux
a déjà participé c'est vous qui avez
déjà participé 9e règle et Nathalie dans
quel état d'esprit êtes-vous le
même démesuré après tout le parcours
pour en arriver là en tout cas
aujourd'hui une très très grosse envie
avant de parler de plus amplement de
votre préparation qui est dû être longue
et éprouvante pour ce raid je vous
propose de voir la préparation justement
de deux autres concurrentes 58
sabriniaciez et milibo nous les avons
suivi à l'entraînement avec Patrick
le raid est souvent ce genre
d'expérience qui vous change et celui de
l'Arbre Vert ne déroge pas à la règle
les 240 participants qui enchaîneront
pendant 5 jours course à pied VTT canoë
ou tir à l'arc dans ce coin de paradis
au milieu de l'océan Indien l'île
Maurice mais Lauren n'est pas seulement
un défi physique c'est aussi une
aventure humaine à 37 ans Émilie beau
participe à son troisième règle marqué
par une première épée inoubliable le
premier jour en fait on a croisé des
tortues dans l'eau et c'était vraiment
on s'est arrêté pour prendre des photos
totalement c'était surprenant et ça ça
donne vraiment envie de repartir quoi
pour vivre des choses
identiques
de son côté Sabrina kiese le découvre à
33 ans à quelques jours du départ la
patience d'iette prend le dessus sur les
derniers imprévus on est passé par
plusieurs phases mais là maintenant
qu'on a vraiment notre équipe qu'on est
trois là on a vraiment envie d'y aller
là on est impatiente alors on fait
attention de pas trop se blesser parce
que faut s'entraîner mais bon voilà on a
pas envie de se blesser avant de partir
donc là on veut on veut partir on veut y
aller
quand sport est solidarité se rejoignent
c'est aussi ça l'expérience du raid
solidaire l'équipe de Sabrina kiese a
choisi d'aider les enfants de l'île
Maurice dans ses valises cette chef de
projet informatique ne transportera pas
que du matériel
on s'est lancé un défi supplémentaire un
défi humanitaire c'est à dire qu'on
emmène la bas des jeux d'éveil des jeux
pédagogiques des livres des fournitures
scolaires pour les enfants de l'île
Maurice après il y a le défi bon bah du
sport c'est le déplacement de soi c'est
vraiment aller voir jusqu'où on peut
aller dépasser ses limites
le raid c'est aussi un état d'esprit où
la cohésion d'équipe est capitale Emilie
beau portant triathlète de formation ne
s'arrête pas la seule performance
sportive souvent primordiale les hommes
parfois c'est un peu macho ils aiment
pas trop qu'on
puisse éventuellement les doubler ce qui
arrive il faut le dire et donc là ça
enlève ce côté justement macho et on est
entre filles il y a vraiment un esprit
de solidarité on cède dès qu'il y a une
fille qui est qui crève ou qui qui a
vraiment un souci
cette année période de Vendée Globe
oblige la voile s'inscrit au programme
des collages pour l'enfer au paradis le
25 novembre
comme le disait Wilfried tout à l'heure
Isabelle c'est votre neuvième arrêt
Amazon ou raid de l'Arbre Vert
maintenant vous avez une anecdote à nous
raconter quelque chose un souvenir qui
vous a marqué qui a fait que c'est
devenu un peu une addiction
le souvenir de l'île Maurice le premier
la première fois j'ai trouvé ça
tellement tellement difficile le canoë
est tellement dur je pense qu'on est
arrivé pas très bien classé probablement
pas loin des dernières et il y avait des
cours en des vents c'était pas facile du
tout et on chantait à tue-tête à la fin
on n'en pouvait plus je me rappelle
encore c'était maman les petits bateaux
pour essayer d'arriver et on avait
l'impression que ça finissait jamais
parce que le paysage quand vous faites
du canoë en mer on a l'impression que ça
ne défile pas ça n'avance pas à côté du
surplace au milieu de nulle part et puis
qu'on dans la semoule enfin qu'on
voilà qu'on n'avance pas et ça c'était
très drôle voilà donc je nous
Revo encore enfin en train de chanter
comme ça tu t'aides pour nous donner du
courage Nathalie c'est vous avez déjà
fait des rênes notamment le reste du
Touquet là c'est votre première aide
arbre vert vous y allez pour l'aventure
humaine plus que la performance sportive
ou les deux jouent le même rôle c'est
pas quand même rôle en fait on y va non
vraiment pour l'aventure humaine
vraiment et sans sans se sans vouloir se
cacher c'est vraiment une aventure
humaine parce que ben on est nombreux
c'est c'est on en a vraiment bavé pour
en arriver là et évidemment au-delà de
ça il y a évidemment une compétition
c'est clair on parle de classement quand
il y a un classement il y a une
compétition mais voyons on est là on est
on est on est voilà on se connaissait
pas il y a 5 minutes on est amis et on
sera amis avec les 80 équipes les 80
autres équipes en tout cas
non c'est vraiment voilà c'est une
aventure humaine un don de soi c'est je
pense que ça va être vraiment une
aventure humaine exceptionnelle en tout
cas ça c'est sûr de bien faire de de
bien figurer au classement final une
grosse envie de se faire énormément
plaisir sans se blesser de revenir en
ayant tout donné tout donné pour soi
pour ses coéquipières pour pour un tout
en fait pour pour les gens qui nous ont
aidés et évidemment il y a oui l'envie
de faire le mieux mais on ne se fixe pas
d'objectif comme ça on n'aura pas de de
on sera pas déçu en tout cas c'est
difficile de connaître la limite aussi
ses propres limites de dire on va tout
donner mais on veut pas se blesser à
quel moment on sait que non il faut pas
aller plus loin c'est c'est quoi c'est
le corps qu'il le dit c'est un instant
de survie on se dit il faut pas aller
plus loin parce qu'on va se blesser
je pense que enfin personnellement si on
s'est un petit peu entraîné on connaît
aussi un peu son corps enfin je veux
dire depuis le temps on fait du sport
alors moi évidemment pas comme Isabelle
j'ai pas fait autant de raides du tout
que Isabelle j'en suis pas à ce niveau
là mais le corps son corps on connaît un
minimum on s'est à peu près et puis
souvent quand le corps ne suit plus
c'est la tête qui va prendre le relais
donc on arrive et c'est d'où l'intérêt
effectivement cette équipe de trois
c'est quand il y en a une qui qui va pas
bien les autres sont là pour booster etc
pour lui dire attention bois fais
attention à toi etc donc finalement la
blessure elle arrive elle arrive
forcément Isabelle en témoigner ça
arrive c'est clair mais on fait
attention et en tout cas on est là pour
se préserver les unes les autres et
faire attention l'une à l'autre cohésion
qui fait aussi une partie de la
performance dans un raid se fait ce fait
que on se dit voilà on est une chaîne
indissociable tous les trois toutes les
trois ensemble et on y va jusqu'au bout
alors ça c'est la base c'est la base on
peut être très bon sportivement avoir un
très bon niveau technique
s'il y a pas cette cohésion là et bien
ça le fait pas ça marche pas parce que
le principe du rêve c'est partir à 3
d'arriver à trois et donc ça suppose de
supporter les faiblesses aussi pour
savoir avec qui on parle sur les
différentes aventures vous avez pu faire
9 red il y a eu des mauvaises surprises
non non parce que je connaissais le
niveau technique mais il me semble que
c'est quand même important d'avoir aussi
un niveau technique à peu près homogène
mais au-delà de ça
énormément énormément il faut se
supporter entre guillemets dans les
moments difficiles parce qu'on est quand
même poussé à bout parfois ça va parce
qu'on garde ses amis après les raids
alors moi toujours
et on est lié à vie je pense voilà à
part cette cohésion il y a d'autres clés
pour réussir son raid d'autres clés dans
une discipline
c'est plus un état d'esprit global et
puis sinon il faut surtout être entraîné
sur du sport d'endurance en général
le la base si vous savez courir environ
une heure et demie sans vous arrêter
vous êtes une femme qui vous entraînez
régulièrement une fois par semaine
ça ça doit le faire après tout est dans
la tête juste l'envie d'y aller juste
l'envie de réussir avec ses ça veut dire
que serait de là de l'Arbre Vert il est
accessible à toutes
Nathalie
moi je pense qu'effectivement c'est
c'est une phrase qui revient sur le site
effectivement red accessible à toute moi
je rajouterais juste sous-entendu enfin
à condition qu'on ait une petite
condition physique à mon avis parce que
comme Isabelle parler du canot et tout à
l'heure il y a des distances notamment
en canoë parce que effectivement c'est
une épreuve à laquelle on est finalement
moins habitué je crois le canoë il y a
des distances qui vont jusqu'à 23 18 et
23 km donc je pense qu'effectivement on
va avoir les nos bras de filles qui vont
qui vont un petit peu brûler donc je
pense qu'effectivement il faut un
minimum de de conditions puis après je
pense que voilà cet élan cette bonne
humeur cette convivialité cette cohésion
va faire qu'on va trouver on va
redoubler de force et à mon avis on va
puiser là où des forces insoupçonnées
départ donc le 25 novembre
dimanche merci à vous et bon courage
pour pour cette course donc ce red
Amazon arbre vert on suivra les
différents résultats que vous allez
pouvoir obtenir on vous souhaite de le
finir et bien classer en plus voilà
c'était juste une petite allez-y moi je
tiens particulièrement et ça nous tient
à toute je ne vais pas les citer
évidemment pour respecter
tout ça et c'est énorme nous ça fait
effectivement depuis qu'on a décidé
depuis le mois donc avril mi avril on a
décidé serait d'ensemble on s'est battu
on s'est transformé en VRP on s'est
vendu partout il y a des gens qui ont
cru en nous et j'espère qu'ils ont eu
raison parce qu'on va leur prouver
qu'ils ont eu raison et donc merci à eux
vraiment vous êtes engagé ce soir
attention
en tout cas et je sais pas comment on
terminera j'espère en bonne santé
je sais pas à quelle place mais en tout
cas on fera notre meilleur et ça il faut
qu'il le voilà qu'ils ont s'assure merci
donc à côté de l'imagine principale qui
est pas citer
c'était bien parti mais c'était pas
sponsors merci beaucoup